jerome powell held a press conference
today in jackson hole wyoming and he had
a lot to say first he came out hot and
he started with the federal reserve must
get back down to a 2 inflation goal
given that we're at 8.5 now we're
getting an f minus and it is going to be
incredibly difficult to get there powell
went on to say that price stability is
incredibly important for the federal
reserve it's literally one of their two
mandates and in order to get price
stability the market has to understand
what's going to happen in the future the
average american family can't live in an
environment where they go to the grocery
store month after month after month and
prices continue to skyrocket even over a
one or two year period you need to have
some stability in the market so that
people can plan their lives and they
understand what they're going to spend
money on and how much it's going to cost
now contrary to popular belief the
federal reserve understands this jerome
powell specifically called out the fact
that high inflation impacts the people
who are least prepared to handle it
that's because in the united states 45
of americans have no investable assets
they don't even know what inflation
really is they just realize that every
time they go to the store prices are
going up and their life is getting more
expensive the wealthiest people in our
country are much better prepared to
handle inflation a very small percentage
of their monthly budgets actually go to
high inflation goods they're usually so
well sophisticated that they understand
how inflation works and of course they
have their investment portfolios which
allow them to actually benefit from high
inflation environments the federal
reserve is in a unique situation they
got to get inflation down but they do
realize that they're gonna have to
create tons and tons of pain for tens of
millions of americans in that effort
powell explicitly called out that pain
is on the horizon that is going to be
the cost of trying to get inflation down
his argument is if we allow inflation to
run wild high inflation is going to be
worse than the pain we'll have to
swallow to get the inflation to come
down
the federal reserve for months now has
been talking about destroying demand
that demand destruction is both in
consumer sentiment of their willingness
to buy goods and services but it's also
in financial markets for investors as
well
we've already seen a little bit of pain
but jerome powell was quite hawkish he
seems to be issuing a warning saying
that there is more pain on the horizon
buckle up strap in and get prepared one
of the areas that he talked about was
the labor market which has historically
been pretty strong we've been sitting
around 3.5
unemployment and there's about 10
million open jobs so if you don't like
yours there's been plenty more that you
could go and get
but given the demand destruction given
the increasing interest rate and the
quantitative tightening that the federal
reserve is pursuing he expects the labor
market to start to soften which means
that unemployment will go up and people
will lose their jobs they say it in all
kinds of fancy ways but that's what he's
talking about people will lose their
jobs unemployment will go up and the
labor market won't look so pretty when
you have tighter financial conditions
when you have interest rates going up
when you have layoffs increasing the us
economy is going to slow down the cost
of capital is getting more expensive and
business owners see an uncertain future
it's harder to invest in r d it's harder
to invest in expansion you simply want
to make sure that you have a strong
balance sheet that you optimize your
cash flow and that you survive these
types of economic downturns
the federal reserve has one specific
focus at the moment the most important
thing is to get inflation down
eight point five percent down to two
means that they're going to have a lot
of work to do but the side effects of
that effort is that there is going to be
further and further economic pain on the
horizon that is true for individuals and
for corporations while you sit at home
and you listen to jerome powell talk
about the federal reserve's view on the
current economic environment what you
need to know is that you should be
acting like every businesses
strengthen your balance sheet and make
sure that you have the cash flow to
survive this economic downturn
no one knows how bad it will get or how
long it will last but what we do know is
that they are telegraphing what is going
to happen the federal reserve is telling
you that they are going to crash the u.s
economy in order to get inflation under
control
if you hear the federal reserve saying
that they will crash the u.s economy
it's probably worth listening as the old
adage says don't fight the federal
reserve they're in control
they say they're going to torpedo this
thing
well you probably should be prepared for
the worst case scenario